over the weekend Avengers endgame earned
a record record 1.2 billion dollars at
the box office
billion yes a lot of people on our staff
saw it and they absolutely loved it I'm
mostly curious about one of our interns
opinions of the movie one of his family
members was actually in Avengers endgame
that's true story let's bring him out
here please welcome Dennis
[Music]
[Applause]
hey hey Dennis thanks for coming out
here hey Conan yeah oh so let me get
this straight
I've been told that you are Thanos's son
yeah yeah Thanos is my dad yeah did we
know that when we hired you as an intern
no no I wanted to get the internship on
my own merit yeah okay so I'm guessing
just from the look of things you and
your dad took kind of different paths in
life yeah yeah he's trying to destroy
half the universe I'm an unpaid gofer
Chavez yeah it's a showbiz right have
you seen Avengers endgame no no my dad's
movies are cool but they're way too loud
too much CGI I'm more of a quiet indie
flick type okay well that's sweet yeah
well now being fan OSes son that means
you possess superhuman abilities so how
has our show been putting your powers to
use well I picked up your dry cleaning
I walked Andy's dog signed all those
headshots for you oh good good yeah yeah
we really know how to harness the talent
around here yeah oh I wanted to ask well
I'm out here do you think I could have
the day off tomorrow yeah tomorrow's not
a great day to be out Dennis where we're
gonna be pretty busy
choose your words wisely O'Brien for I
rule raining Hellfire on your show the
entire studio reduced okay well you know
you do that and you won't be able to
meet Dax Shepard he's on tomorrow's show
Dax Shepard is on tomorrow
well this wife Kristen Bell will be
coming along
yeah she usually comes along yeah I love
the good place I'll be here
okay great god by the way did you pick
up my aunt Minn it has to be
refrigerated I know I know I'm getting
it now okay great great give a hand
goodbye everyone
Danis everybody she's a good kid